you know what's great about the future
we don't have to carry around a giant
sketchbook
and a hundred pencils anymore all we
need is one ipad
and one app
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is david
thomich and welcome back to the channel
if you're new here firstly thank you so
much for joining me on this channel we
talk about technology and architecture
today we're talking about one of my
favorite apps and it's more folio trace
as a registered architect i use a lot of
different apps for a lot of different
things however i found morfolio trace to
be one of the most practical and useful
to date
so if you're thinking why does this guy
use morfolio trace instead of procreate
well it's simple as an architect i use
morpholio trace to better
understand what i have to do later i
don't use it for presentation drawings
or
pretty 3d renders i genuinely use it in
meetings
when discussing with clients to better
understand their needs
and that way i can utilize it later down
the track so there are a number of ways
i use morpholio trace and the first
is import and overlay you simply import
the current drawings that you're working
on
or whoever is working on into more folio
trace and you start
marking them up you use it exactly the
same as if that drawing set was printed
but instead of having to go through
hundreds and hundreds of pages you can
just go through one document
once that document is completed and
fully marked up you can quickly send
that document off
and you don't have to wait for them to
again either get
it or print it or do whatever so overall
i think this is a very practical way of
using morpholio trace so the second way
i use morpholi trace is when you're
actually very far away
so if i'm having a teams meeting or a
zoom meeting or anything
like that i can actually sync up my ipad
to that meeting
and share that screen so instead of
having that client talk to you directly
and draw on a piece of paper like you
would in an actual meeting
this way you can bring up the drawings
and you can still sketch up and mark up
and actually understand what they're
trying to get at now what happens when
you're that little bit
too close for comfort well morfolio
trays can still be used as a sketchbook
so you don't have to bring out your
giant rolls of trace paper
and lots of markers and textures you can
utilize morpholio trace
as a diagrammatical tool or presentation
tool
i just personally don't have those
skills i never really tried to learn how
to be an artist
i just learned how to be an architect so
if you do have those skills
on board and you're a great artist as
well as a good architect or aspiring
architect
morfolio trace has those abilities built
in ready to go
i guess one of the last and least used
features of morfolio trace is the ar
ability
and being able to actually showcase your
designs in the real world
this technology is up and coming
throughout all different platforms and
softwares
so it's going to be used more and more
however right now
it definitely isn't used and it
definitely doesn't count as a pro
towards more folio trace now you've
already flipped the money for a brand
new ipad
and a pencil that costs an absurd amount
of money for what it actually is
incredibly useful tool nonetheless one
of the downsides of morpholia trace is
the simple fact that it costs a decent
amount of money
if you want to continue to use it at a
higher level so for example i use quite
a few of the features in morfolio trace
and i use it quite a bit so i've had to
purchase the premium plan which is
almost 30 australian dollars per year
procreate as a competitor is only 15 for
the entire app
so you might be able to weigh up your
options here depending how long you
actually use it for
however if you're looking to spend a
couple hundred dollars on an ipad
a couple hundred dollars on a pencil and
then another thirty forty fifty dollars
on morfolio trace every single year well
you might find yourself running out of
food in the fridge pretty quickly
so once you buy a new ipad and once you
buy a morpholia trace you've spent
a pretty decent amount of money
anyway that's all for me today guys
thanks so much for watching i hope you
enjoyed it
if you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below and because
this forms one of my 28 videos in 28
days for february of
2021 it would usually be i'll see you
next monday
but in this case i'll see you tomorrow